oh my god
oh [__] okay if you're a creep near
London or Dublin listen up tickets are
officially on sale now for our upcoming
London and Dublin tour so get those
tickets and meet us there that's right
in case you missed the announcement
we're bringing the podcast to London and
Dublin and all four of us will be
performing live on April 16th at Royal
Albert Hall and at three Arena on April
7th how do you say Royal Albert Hall
three times fast Royal Albert Hall Royal
Albert Hall Royal Albert Hall it's
difficult it's difficult to do we can't
wait to jump across the pond so head to
the alwayssonypod.com for tickets and
details hey get them all they're hot
because once they're gone they're gone
see you soon
good